bonsoir mesdames et messieurs les élus
les maires les citoyens attendait la
décision de québec qu'est ce qu'il y
aura un très léger électrique pour le
transport en commun sur le nouveau pont
champlain
réponse de robert poëti ministre des
transports on ne sait pas on décidera
l'an prochain mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à l'ouverture du pont du nouveau pont
ce sera françois cormier des autobus
absolument parce qu'il est impossible
selon les politiciens de mettre en place
le système de slr pour l'ouverture du
pont en 2018 donc pendant une période
d'année qui pourraient s'échelonner
jusqu'à 2021 2022 voire même peut-être
2023 il y aura donc des autobus je suis
partie aurait pu dire qu'il y aurait un
slr tout de suite qu'il mettrait en
place laissait l'air ce n'est pas ce
qu'il fait aujourd'hui ce qu'il dit
c'est qu'il n'a pas assez d'informations
pour prendre cette décision là alors ils
demandent à l'aiea une telle agence
métropolitaine de transport d'aller
faire des devoirs finalement ils
demandent des études supplémentaires
pour pouvoir prendre la décision en 2015
monsieur politi a évoqué aujourd'hui des
chiffres on sait depuis une semaine donc
accélère coûterait environ 1,4 à 2
milliards de dollars aujourd'hui il a
même parlé de 2,5 voire même 2,6
milliards de dollars on ne sait pas
exactement à quel endroit il prend ces
chiffres là et elle est il dit qu'il n'a
pas assez donc d'information pour
prendre sa décision à l'heure actuelle
on peut l'écouter il n'y a pas que l'on
aime tu es là dedans et aussi le
ministère des transports et la ville de
montréal il ya beaucoup de gens d'être
interpellé on voit dans un site urbain
quand qu'on n'entame en rien alors à
partir de là les coûts parfois peuvent
être étonnants et actuellement cette
brèche est là pour moi un trop grand et
on va devoir être capable d'avoir
justement avec ce chantier de projets
acceptés études d'opportunité un chef
beaucoup plus réaliste sur la réalité
des coûts d'un option ou dans l'eau et
c'est ça que monsieur girard et son
groupe de travail vont m'aider à prendre
le dessus
réaction françois des maires de la
région
mais monsieur coderre essaie de nous
convaincre qu'il ne faut pas chercher
des poux finalement que c'est une
décision raisonnable de vouloir plus
d'informations par contre sur la rive
sud de montréal on sent beaucoup plus de
déception on aurait un et donc que le
gouvernement aille de l'avant avec le
projet de slr on peut donc écouter les
meilleurs coderre mais aussi la mairesse
st-hilaire de longueuil et le maire
leduc de brossard
puis on voit convaincre le gouvernement
que on a besoin du slr c'est un projet
structurant qui est essentiel qui est
important forts de notre unanimité à
l'hôtel de ville fort de notre unanimité
au niveau de la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal on va se
donner les outils pour pleinement
s'égaliser essais mi figue mi raisin et
on s'est un peu un i win sinon on est
inquiet parce que c'est plus de 20000
personnes qui prennent le pont en
transport en commun alors aujourd'hui on
leur dit mme attendent encore un peu de
voir actuellement que des autobus vous
circulez
je suis pas là plusieurs années mais
c'est sûr qu'on peut craindre que les
salaires ne voit jamais le jour
et françois le fédéral de son côté
semble d'accord l'idée on demande la
pour l'instant tablier bred qui peut
recevoir des autobus d'abord et
peut-être un jour en jour en jour dans
le train oui le gouvernement harper nous
envoyer une réaction écrite vous pouvez
en lire un extrait nous avions déjà
commencé dit il a planifié la conception
de tabliers centrale hybride dans le
cadre du projet de corridor du nouveau
pont pour le saint laurent soit un
tablier qui puisse accueillir temps un
système léger sur rail que des autobus
c'est donc ce qui verra le jour et le
gouvernement fédéral qui précise que ça
ne retardera pas finalement l'ouverture
du pont prévue en 2018 merci françois
avec nous pour poursuivre sur ce sujet
important robert poëti moon et des
transports responsables la région de
montréal bonsoir monsieur politi bonjour
monsieur mais je vous entends déjà
conférence de presse monsieur pointu
dire je ne recule pas or il ya un an
même il ya un an et un mois exactement
j'ai connu presse devant moi le 19 avril
puis je vais vous lire une petite phrase
de rien le ministre godeau le ministre
des transports l'époque annonce la
création d'un bureau de projet afin de
concrétiser la mise en place du slr un
budget de 27 millions et cetera sera
alloué pour ainsi sa mission donc la
décision elle était prise une arme ce
psy d'aller vers un slr pourquoi vous la
remettez en question pourquoi vous
reculez écoutez mon premièrement je
jauge est encore de vous et vous pouvez
pas et que je recule et je suis obligé
de vous dire que cette décision-là est
en partie c'est évidemment monsieur
bédard stéphane bédard qui était
président du conseil du trésor en
février 2014 et madame marois qui nous
imposent d'une certaine façon cette
décision parce que à ce moment là une
nouvelle directive du conseil du trésor
lorsqu'il y avait des poursuite des
études évidemment lorsqu'on parle d'un
dossier d'opportunités février 2014 à la
demande de monsieur bédard du conseil du
trésor les dossiers d'opportunités
doivent absolument avoir à l'intérieur
du dossier d'opportunités des
comparaisons des prix des indications
des recommandations sur ce qui est le
plus efficace pour quelle raison et être
capable d'arriver dans un saint un
charme détaillé de comparaison pour être
capable d'évaluer la meilleure
proposition sur cette directive du
conseil du trésor février 2014 et dans
lequel nous amène la fin du rapport de
monsieur gérard de la mt à la fin de
l'été 2015 alors c'est un peu comme si
vous demandiez de court circuiter une
directive du conseil du trésor on le
fera pas deuxièmement on recule parce
qu'il faut comprendre sur loin même si
on décide est aujourd'hui l'on avait
décidé tous ensemble on veut un salaire
là la bonne nouvelle est malheureusement
c'est que on a un nouveau pont qui ont
une échéance plutôt de réalisation d'une
bonne nouvelle ça alors ça veut dire
qu'en 2018 le pont vont être là si on
mettait un salaire partant du principe
sera construit efficace en 2018 il va
traverser le pont champlain qui voit
s'arrêter au bout parce que du pont
champlain au centre-ville de montréal
c'est pour moi qui le dis là c'est
monsieur girard c'est physiquement est
possible irréalisable de penser de dire
qu'il serait voilerait monsieur prix
s'est livré au près puis on comprend
c'est à la limite on tirait été mais on
pourrait décider le gouvernement du
québec pourrait décider néanmoins de
dire notre choix à moyen terme c'est un
train c'est un train léger non polluants
il ya 900 autobus par jour qui arrivent
à montréal les gens s'en plaignent
depuis des années c'est la voile d'avant
non mais ils froid là la voie d'avenir
je la réserve parce que j'aurais pu dire
aujourd'hui et là vous pourriez dire que
je recule qu'on a on ne retient pas les
salaires j'aurais pu dire ça aujourd'hui
nous aurions pu décider ça je pense que
je fais monsieur roy ce que je dis là
c'est impossible
2021-2022 d'être endurant montréal mais
moi ce que je dis on veut préserver
l'avenir je vais être capable
lorsqu on décidera de le faire d'avoir
la possibilité technique de pouvoir le
réaliser
c'est que n'attendez pas l'étude qui est
en marche qui coûte 28 millions de la mt
pour vous donner un portrait réel la
situation en amérique 6 mais surtout m
le milieu politique claire avec le
public l'a quand même oui tu d'elles a
été commandé pour mettre en marche
projet-là l'a pas été commandé pour
comparer autobus et trains non mais là
le juge
unique est ici plus sympa et y met du
sien ya prise mais qui le fait de
communiquer monsieur loire le ministère
des transports c'était les mêmes
fonctionnel d'entrée pour vous
aujourd'hui attention kiki était au
pouvoir la ce moment leur parti
québécois ok alors où en février
attendues le 6 mai fait 10 février 2014
qui était au pouvoir et qui a demandé
avec le conseil du trésor les directives
sur les dossiers de projets si monsieur
bédard alors il écrit j'ai peu joué mais
je comprends pas que vous interprétez un
recul quand nous on demande à ottawa et
vous avez déjà la réponse d'ailleurs je
suis je suis heureux qu'ils aient
répondu aussi rapidement devenu un nom
louis alors à partir de leurs ce que ça
dit c'est qu'on est ouvert sur l'avenir
parce que l'avenir de 2018 19-20-21 ne
permettait pas et cela alors qu'est ce
que ça nous c'est d'être pressé de dire
ça on n'est pas mieux d'avoir livré cher
monsieur nord dans un an la décision si
on comprend bien aujourd'hui et sera
finale dans un an on se retient jouir un
train
dans trois quatre cinq six ans sur louis
vous avez raison effectivement dans une
impasse que ce pont là a une durée de
vie combi ottawa 225 1 alors à partir de
leur moi je pense que de ne pas faire ça
ce serait pas sage et ne pas permettre
l'avenir et la possibilité d'avoir un
salaire aurait été une grave erreur il
me semble que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle mais sur ce point si on va se
reparler de 110,6 un âge le sans merci
certains seraient leur a versé en vain